it's clearly um a decision that is
um not straightforward and um
a decision that in the end i could only
take on the information that i have
i've spoken with harry um i have
the the insight to the story which is
very different to what's being reported
and in these instances i think you can
only make decisions on facts that you're
aware of
um now clearly if um
if facts change further down the line or
information changes then
i have to review that decision but um
i have a fantastic relationship with the
boy um
harry has been outstanding character for
us
i've no reason to doubt what he's
telling me and
um you know it's important he knows that
he's got my support at this moment
so if he were to be found guilty because
obviously this is ongoing right now
he could be dropped from the squad still
well
i'm not going to get into hypotheticals
of what might or might not happen rob
but
as i said i've got to reserve the right
to review
um if further information becomes
available i think whenever you're
in a management position you have to
make lots of decisions and you always
make decisions to the best of your
ability
given the information that you have and
people might
agree or disagree with those decisions
um
but um you know i think that i think
that's the position every manager finds
themselves and
and at this moment in time that that's
where i am with it
um as i said harry um regrets the fact
that he's brought
that sort of focus and uh attention on
on the team and he he apologized for
that
um but he also has his own side of the
story that i think will come out in time